hallo hier sind erst carina saskia
marlin lavinia besuch in utah die
familie genau wie besuchen heute eine
fan vielleicht habt ihr schon
mitbekommen wir sind gerade vier wochen
in namibia um mit dem goethe-institut
ein projekt zu machen nämlich deutsch in
namibia zu zeigen und mit schulen medien
an medien zu arbeiten und unser thema
heute ist das typische farm leben in
namibia
wir gehen jetzt auf die farm an wir
treffen dort einen deutschen fahrer der
uns alles erklärt was wir wissen wollen
und letzter
bei uns ist er trotzdem besitzen wir
fahren heute alles was man über das vom
leben im name wir wissen muss wie kann
man die landschaft beschrieben
also wir leben hier im kongo und das
ganze gebirge besteht hier eigentlich
alles aus granit und diese ganzen
bitteren informationen die man hier
hinter uns sieht werden alle geschaffen
durch hitze und das nennen wir dann
immer auch den wollten was ist der volt
effekt ja der wolga effekt
das muss man sich so vorstellen das
kommt durch den jutesack durch dass
diese farbe das gleiche wie so ein wolf
ein jutesack hat deswegen spricht man
hier von diesen kann nicht voll sagt
effekt welche direkt gibt es auf die
form
ja wir sind hier in dem roman reinders
entrust und wir haben uns verschrieben
dass wir nur in dem die daten hier
aussetzen und die bekanntesten will
daten die wir hier haben ist dass
hartmann zebra den kodex dann haben wir
gelassen das schwarz nasen impala und
natürlich auch unsere nashörner
wie wird man den pharma
ja leidenschaft
einfach leidenschaft trinken
mehr kann man nicht sagen
kann man das hier in irgendeiner schule
lernen ein doch du kannst pharma
natürlich wendet aufnahme grad schule
lernen aber
ich denke
liebe zum land die liebe zum farmen dass
es was der im endeffekt das meiste
bringt
was sind wir jetzt jetzt sind wir hier
bei den felsmalereien die wahrscheinlich
oder wir nehmen an die buschleute gemalt
haben
und wir haben hier auf der farm ungefähr
92 fundstellen passieren wir hier kann
man sehr schön erkennen zwei giraffen
einmal die eine die nach rechts und
einmal die nach links kopf und dann auch
den legendären köcher bbl sind die
malereien
das ist schwierig um zu sagen aber wir
nehmen an dass sie zwischen 200 und 2000
jahre alt sind muss was haben sie gemalt
okay wir haben wahrscheinlich nehmen sie
diesen weißen weichen stein und wenn man
das hier unten rein guckt haben sie den
hier fein gemahlen
wir können das mal hier drauf kratzen
dann seht ihr die farbe die darunter
kommt und das haben sie wahrscheinlich
dann mit blut gemischt und damit gemalt
ja weil das wahrscheinlich in dem blut
im eisenoxid drin ist und das ja auch
sozusagen sagen wir mal rostet und dann
ist der granitfelsen sehr sehr rau und
dann frisst sich das richtig in den
granitfelsen rein und dann kommt das
regenwasser mit der kieselsäure die da
drüber geht
und deswegen sind die wahrscheinlich so
gut erhalten weil sie das wahrscheinlich
aus geprobt haben es mit allen sachen so
wenn man ist oder was man isst anfällt
feld kosten man suchte so ich denke sie
mussten halt sehr sehr viel probieren
und ich denke sie waren sich gar nicht
dessen bewusst dass diese felsmalereien
überhaupt so lange
den wänden halten werden wir haben
gerade leoparden spuren gesehen
kannst du das noch mal kurz auf deutsch
sagen was sehen wir hier hier sehen wir
jetzt eine schöne leoparden spur
ich sage immer dass der guckt ob ich
hier war und ich kooperiere bei dem
leopard und geppert unterschied wie man
das erkennen kann es immer dass bei dem
leopard keine kleinen vorne zu sehen
sind also die märkte von der von den
kleinen und wann war der hier
der war heute morgen hier das war heute
morgen nach dem jackie zu beurteilen und
der frisch von den spuren ist er heute
morgen hier zu sonnen auf einmal lang
ich bin ein leopard reingelaufen
gekommene untertasse leopard ungefähr
fünf meter vor mir sehe ich sagen der
leopard hatte ich so viel mehr
erschrocken
der ist in die richtung gerannt und ich
bin in die richtung nach 100 metern
haben wir alle beide gedacht
seinen lappen
st
ja ich bin jetzt hier mitten im busch
die gruppen hat mich einfach stehen
mai
ich bin johannes und wo sind wir jetzt
hier das ist eine wasserstelle eine
künstliche wasserstelle die mein opa
schon ganz früh hier als erstes auf der
farm gebaut hat und da hinten kann man
das windrad sehen was das wasser von
ungefähr 100 meter fördert aus dem boden
und das ist natürlich eine wasserstelle
wo die ganzen wildtiere sowie der rics
und cool und hat man zebra hier trinken
kommen er ist ein streng
warum das ist ein salz lag stein die
tiere hier haben mich genug kongo und
deswegen machen wir überwiegend für die
kubus diese salz lag steine in dem baum
und für die orix und das restliche welt
machen wir die auf dem boden
das macht dieses gutachten
wir haben viel gelernt wir haben viel
kostet und das war ein wunderbar ausflug
wir halten wir hoffen euch gefällt unser
video
danke für sich schauen die spiel
heute zum abschluss der episode
ausnahmsweise kein lang mit stück von
dana sondern von mir carina was ihr
heute ein video gesehen hat ist
vielleicht ein bisschen anderes deutsch
als das was ihr sonst so lernt denn auch
in namibia wird deutsch gesprochen von
einer deutschen minderheit die hier
durch die geschichte immer noch lebt und
vielleicht ist euch aufgefallen dass das
deutsch ein bisschen anders ist man kann
sagen es ist auch ein anderer dialekt
und es gibt ein paar einflüsse in dem
deutsches klingt manchmal ein bisschen
härter das deutsch und manche
grammatischen strukturen sind auch
verändert vielleicht ist euch
aufgefallen dass der harald im video
gesagt hat das ist schwierig um zu sagen
das ist so eine struktur die ihr aus dem
niederländischen oder aus dem
afrikanischen kennt und das hat sich
hier in namibia auch vermischt das als
kleiner tipp für euch danke fürs
zuschauen wenn ihr uns unterstützen
möchte freuen wir uns wahnsinnig über
euren support denn damit könnt ihr unser
projekt unserem projekt sehr
weiterhelfen hier unten könnt ihr uns
bei katrin unterstützen und abonniert
natürlich unseren kanalisieren
damit ihr mehr sehen könnt danke und bis
zur nächsten woche